qu'est ce que vous voyez pour pour pour
l'émission et pour moi ce que vous voyez
quelque chose pour moi alors en ce qui
vous concerne et vous oui c'est bien
venu évidemment et je maintiens vous
serez pour moi il y aura un autre enfant
chez vous d'accord d'autres enfants très
jeunes au club
phil barney touareg à vous allez
relancer de nouveau un nouveau défi ah
oui vous allez refaire un nouveau défi
vous n'allez pas perdre et rendre
prazeres vous allez faire au moins 48
heures de direct
oui mais vous serez vous serez
accompagnés par une femme tu as tort
serait accompagné par une femme se
serait ce serait une femme âgée d'une
quarantaine d'années donc c'est pas
isabelle morini bosc
apparemment ça peut être ça peut être
sophie cost c'est vrai que ça peut être
vous que j'y crois moi et qu est-ce que
je vais rester sur ses roues alors au
programme reste sur 6 8 pour progresser
sur ces 8
maintenant moi je vois quand même parti
a soufflé sur canal+ à ses animateurs
qu'est-ce que cyril sera toujours
animateur et encore je dirais à peu près
un an voire deux ans élu il fera des
commandes et à des émissions
exceptionnelles de spécial mais les
spéciales mais après pour moi ils voient
la csn en mer du décor zen après je vois
japon puis une association qui va se
faire par rapport à un homme un homme
qui a déjà été jugé non dans l'actualité
sur les par le passé et vous rentrerez
suez dans un gros groupe
il est déjà là gourou ce numéro mondial
non mais il ya autre chose après quatre
semaines peut-être pas mais s'il vous
plaît arrêtez
j'adore le handball au sibac août en
tout cas c'est pas si fou ce que vous
dites non j'aime ayant tous les cas y
avait vraiment quelque chose qui prend 1
vous allez vous déplacer même vous serez
même invité son nez sur les chaînes
étrangères peu ce qui est une bonne
assiette
si je prends des cours après attention
ça peut être des programmes sujets que
vous vendez avec la coque très bien
merci